menos alcohol menos acuoso sexual es lo
que aseguran aficionadas al fútbol a
raíz de su experiencia en el mundial de
Qatar
Yo no bebo pero sí me siento más segura
porque cuando hay alcohol la gente está
más alterada Así que nos sentimos más
seguras
no importa si los partidos terminan
tarde por la noche o si vuelves a tu
hotel muy tarde te sientes segura en
todas partes
la restricciones al consumo de alcohol
en la monarquía del Golfo han causado
que mujeres occidentales aficionadas al
deporte acostumbradas a sufrir acoso en
celebraciones regadas de alcohol lleguen
a alabar el ambiente en Qatar así lo
declaró en un artículo para el periódico
británico de Times la inglesa El Limón
directora de her game to también su
partido una campaña para mejorar las
experiencias de las mujeres en los
ámbitos deportivos no lo son y muchas
otras aficionadas inglesas aseguran que
este mundial podría servir de modelo
para los juegos en casa venir aquí ha
sido un verdadero shock dijo moloson no
ha habido silbidos acoso o sexismo de
ningún tipo unas declaraciones que se
viralizaron y levantaron polémica hasta
el punto que la activista aclaró su
comentario las redes sociales afirman
que dije que era seguro para todas las
mujeres nunca lo dije nunca ignoraría
las leyes anti lgbt y las leyes de
tutela de las mujeres
Qatar es objeto de críticas
internacionales por su legislación
opresiva con las mujeres y las personas
lgbtq más sin embargo el bienestar
expresado por mujeres extranjeras en el
mundial es revelador de una problemática
normalizada en occidente